People generally assume,
here's the thing that I could do this
risk and the baseline they compare that to
is no risk.
But that's wrong.
Always.
It's risky or risky.
It's the risk of doing something versus
the risk of not doing something or if
the risk of doing this instead of this,
it's like risk is everywhere.
So do people make foolish
risks while sometimes,
obviously it's foolish to go play slot
machine because the bloody thing is
stacked against you.
So on average you're going to lose.
But you can't tell that to the
person who just won the jackpot.
Well the gamble partly because it's fun,
you know,
like,
and I mean that technically most of the
neurochemicals that your brain producers
that are associated with the kind
of pleasure that people really like,
which is like for example,
the kind of pleasure that drugs like
cocaine produce are produced by um,
risky,
hi,
risky behavior that has the
potential for high return.
We liked that sort of thing.
And people are wired so that they're
more responsive to the probability of
something good happening
then even to the good thing.
So,
for example,
we know that if people win the lottery,
I'll be here later.
They're about the same as they were,
no better,
no worse.
So actually winning all that money
has a limited longterm impact on their
happiness.
That's probably more determined
by their tray temperament,
but the lead up to the good event,
that's the exciting part.
It might happen.
That's excitement.
And that's produced by like gambling.
What produced that?
Especially for some people,
because some people are really
susceptible to that kind of reward.
Everyone susceptible to it to some degree,
and that can be manipulated and
that's what a slot machines do.
Like slot machines manipulate the human
propensity to engage in a certain kind
of gambling behavior.
And why do people gamble?
Sometimes taking a risk really pays off
and not taking a risk is also a risk.
So there's no way out of risk.
It's to gamble one way or another.